this is it this is Tsarskoe v2 the novel
coronavirus that first appeared in
humans in late 2019 these are some of
the first close-up views of the virus
made using a very specific imaging
technique that can see things far too
small to be visible under normal
microscope they show us how the virus
moves inside the human body and how it
hijacks our cells using these these
spikey crowns give the karana virus its
name and they're the key to
understanding how to beat it to get this
right
I need to bring in two experts the first
is my colleague Liz's dead Frank
he teaches material science and
engineering at Ohio State University
this helps me that you are interested in
electron microscopy yes so that's how
you pronounce it okay that's a good
start and the other is Beth Fischer her
team at NIDA the National Institute of
allergies and infectious diseases
created those initial images of the
virus the ones you'll start to notice
imbedded in news articles around the
internet I think for a lot of people
there's a lot of mystery to this viruses
there are two other viruses that emerge
so let's start with how these images
were made the first thing you need to
know is that the corona virus is very
very very small around 100 nanometers to
put that into context if you take out a
ruler and look at one of the millimeter
markings you can fit 10,000 virus
particles inside of that at that size
it's invisible to us even under a
standard light microscope like the one
you might have used in grade school
that's because the smallest wave lengths
of light humans can see measure around
400 nanometers not small enough for the
corona virus to be visible in order to
see something that small you need an
electron microscope how does it actually
differ from what we would think of as a
microscope instead of light we're using
electrons and electrons you think of as
particles but if you take the electrons
trip it out for the atom and accelerate
it in the field and make a climb fast if
you make it move fast enough it actually
will behave as a wave as well and that
wavelength is much much smaller than the
light waves we use in
standard microscope now you're like six
seven eight nine orders of magnitude
smaller and size so now you can see
smaller stuff if you look they're
Knights coronavirus flicker page you'll
come across two distinct types of images
SEM and TEM they're made using two
different types of electron microscopes
a scanning electron microscope or SEM
scans the surface of a sample and
records what bounces back sort of like
how satellite imaging works it gives you
the basic topography of whatever you're
looking at with realistic lighting
similar to photography shadow and
relative size of objects shows you their
placement and how they move through the
cell a transmission electron microscope
or TEM goes way deeper it records the
inner details of a sample by
transmitting electrons through it and
projecting a cross-section of its inner
structure so it's part of the basic
science research to try and understand
structurally what's going on images from
both microscopes are taken in black and
white the color is added later for
clarity like in this SEM image where
virus particles colored in yellow are
seen emerging from the surface of a cell
colored blue and pink when examined
together these images can help
scientists start to figure out how the
corona virus works there's ways to start
then understanding how is it getting in
a cell how is it harnessing that cell
machinery to make more of itself can you
just tell me kind of what we're looking
at here so this is a single viral
particle and the yellow you see it's the
core of the virus itself and then the
corona where corona viruses get their
name and started that halo around it
that's an orange that Corona is the key
to understanding how the virus hijacks
ourselves the Spike proteins that
surround the virus attach to a host
cell's membrane and then penetrate it
once it forces its way in it spreads its
RNA around the host cell multiplies
exits and repeats which makes us sick so
if we can find those two-bike proteins
up with something like an antibody it'll
prevent them from be able to attach and
enter cells which is exactly how we've
beaten back viruses with similar spiky
proteins before this was a 3d rendering
of the Ebola virus you see all those
proteins on the surface so we talked
about the spike
that's what we're talking about no
matter which virus were looking at this
is HIV actually so this is printed after
we do our cryo TEM and you can see all
these little tiny proteins distributed
on the surface and these are the
proteins that we change a target for
vaccine development you want to lock
these up so they're tied up and unable
them to stick to a cell surface is there
anything about the images specifically
that you'd want to share with our
audience that maybe you think will be
helpful for them to know I think when
you can face your enemy it takes a
little bit of the fear factor out of it
I think it's just understanding what it
is we're looking at how it works within
our bodies but to show that this is
something that can be tackled and
overcome I think it's important to know
[Music]